all right so I've just done my
substitution I've just put that in for
cosine and put that in facade okay now
remember I said things are going to get
a little bit worse before they're going
to get better we're used to this right
when we do trig identities like regular
trig identities you're like okay
sometimes you're going to add something
and subtracted or multiplied and divider
to make things make sense okay it's
going to happen a little more before we
get there have a look what I've got here
I notice there's all these powers of X
this is just a fancy polynomial right
well the normal way I write polynomials
is with the powers in order right so
what I need to do is you can see these
guys here and they're actually
interleave right there a serious that
it's one series it's just some of them
have eyes on them because that makes
sense so I'm gonna write the whole thing
but our stuff in one the next term
should be going in terms of quarter in
degree rather here's our IX jeunesse
that speaks to the one term okay with
the X quitter it's here - yep and then
the next one all the odd ones have Y's
on them and actually it's a - I believe
it's a - right
yes is that okay this next one I've been
here yeah
where's the five plus
where's the six two months
I think if I did one more way enough -
okay oops
okay now admittedly you rose look at
that and think mmm not really seeing
much there okay and that's fine what I
want you to notice with me is the size
there's something weird
Janice the signs do something we there
were two series here each of which
alternated plus minus plus minus so when
you put them together have a look at the
sign that in fact if you got another hot
on color highlight this with me right
look at the signs you've got plus plus
and then you get minus minus and then
you get another plus plus and then
another - - and the next ones will be
plus plus and then minus minus plus plus
minus minus plus plus minus minus if I
see anything else today + - - like plus
plus minus 1 and then plus plus and then
minus - do you remember that with me so
so what's going on here
stay with me please I'm begging you
right what's going on here and of course
I expect you to notice that I'm giving
you the whirlwind tour right what that
suggests to me is that like you know
there's some eyes here
like there's wonder you want anyone here
to talk what that suggests to me and
these sites suggests to me is that there
are some extra eyes hiding in there
there extra eyes hiding in there right
like it's as if we multiplying by I over
and over again in fact if you have a
look for instance this is a bit
suspicious see this one here this is X
to the 4 right and it's come back to +1
well which one did that car lunch is
that's item the four right inside the
four if this time before I just carry
with me how many eyes do you think is
supposed to be here I think there are
five because look there's the one that's
already there plus another 4 cos
remember multiplying by either for
doesn't change a number because it's
just one so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna rewrite this
with some extra eyes you know okay but
just be careful so is that our out the
front uh how many eyes are there in the
first ten there are zero I to the zero
how many X's on it also zero
I'm just writing it like that so I can
see the pattern just a little bit uh
hello goose on what's already got the
right number right it's just I'm the one
next to the one ah now hold on a second
there are eyes hiding in here out there
right this should be how many of them
this should be two eyes I swear but if I
if I take out and I swear that that sign
gets changed right so this will be plus
I squared x squared on to effect are you
with me yes you mean this one here and
this one yeah
how about this one how many eyes are
given three okay I'm saying you get a
bit sick of this right now right the
pattern took me a lot longer to write
out this time because I was like I keep
it keeps changing but here it's like oh
no this is it it just keeps on doing the
same thing the next one of me I'm before
X to the 4 on 4 factorial and then I to
them whatever right so I'm just going to
go doctor doctor can write this a little
bit because boys terms on the top in the
product right having the same power
right therefore I can write these as I x
^ naught right and I x2 have one
yeah and I x ^ - do you get the idea so
this this function of X this function of
X is not just the function of X it's a
function in my ex right IX appears every
single time right so I could replace it
with a different label a different label
right so what I'm gonna do I need to
introduce I need I need more management
basically I'm running out of letters
okay so I'm gonna call this - stay with
me I'm gonna call this F of capital X
can you do that with me I can't use Z
does that mean something else I don't
want to use Y because that's just
confusing
I don't need capital X so basically this
is r times X to the north on door
factorial X to the 1 on 1 factorial x
squared I'm gonna do one more you'll see
why this thing
okay